here is a sketch with a woman playing  ted cruz big bird and uh pete davidson  is joe rogan  well that's right  i used to host fear factor and now  doctors fear me  can you help me joe oh sure thing big  bird you see i took carlos mencia down i  could take covet  here's some zinc  an ayahuasca  and some horse medicine  why would a bird take horse medicine i'm  a human and i took horse medicine  and i'm speaking of things that uh are  horse-like  uh today's two sponsors are the letters  s and d as in i can s my own d  do they not even have to try an  impression  they never looked like they were reading  before right they look like the last two  years this was just staring at a cue  card like s and i can s my own d